on
[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants pour soi le japon
j'espère que vous êtes sagement allez
vous coucher hier soir comme nicolas et
pimprenelle nos deux nouveaux petits
amis au trot nounours me dit que vous
avez tous étaient sages comme des images
c'est très bien ça et j'espère que vous
continuerez à nous faire plaisir
soyez tranquille pas trop je les connais
moi les petits enfants
on peut leur faire confiance alan
descend vite voir pimprenelle et nicolas
je suis sûr qu ils t'attendent vous
ordre nicolas qui tu crois que le petit
marchand de sable s'arrêtera au dessus
de la maison ce soir
bien sûr le nom soit promis retient soir
les enfants gentil tellement d'accord
les amis on va faire une belle ronde
chanter je me sens en forme ce soir on y
va
la ronde du rove yeux et toi si nicolas
mais ne marche pas sur les pieds
au menu dont on a du culot toile ballon
les enfants on ne se dispute pas
[Musique]
là une rose pour ta prône l une pour
nicolas moi j'en garde deux car je suis
plus gros vous êtes prêts
attention musique maestro +44 d'une
charmante aux couleurs quand la nuit est
arrivé pour le blues
quand la nuit est d'arriver mais à
travers condensé de fini 4es cornichons
n'ont d'autres champignons non cotre
boutures on met mois et les et messieurs
mes boutons de rose dans ce tout les 4
entre eux à l'égout dans mes yeux comme
le sommeil élevé de tout eau de rose la
valeur aux yeux nez dans la rosée par la
voie des clébards bouger pour le reste
un journal
[Musique]
pitié et ben maintenant on remet les
roses town car ils doivent faire d'auto
com
koki que l'enfant exemple
[Musique]
banier j'accuse t'es mignon disait vrai
dormez vite la gt
la lumière aux ne peut trop flou au plus
court ou aux beaux produits
coupet
[Musique]
elle vous a plu cette jolie ronde oui et
bien vous allez faire comme nicolas et
pimprenelle rendre assez vite vos
parents est allé sagement au dodo à te
voilà nounours tu as une très belle voix
tu sais je suis potro unicolore mode ou
je te dis
allons en route mini en nounours bonne
nuit des enfants à demain
repos bonne nuit
[Musique]
oh